we had alleged bullying right now this
is an amazing example alleged
Bachelorette egg I was mainly talking
about Kaelyn and Cassie and definitive
baby pacifier ring take it to timeout
it's time for roses and Rose a hi
everybody this top is weird but I have
lauren zima and we are here to talk
about the bachelors women tell all
I can't move my arms but I can move them
enough to reach for this champagne we
have just been through so much this week
the fence jump oh the women tell all and
I thought I will just treat myself with
my favorite things wine and snacks I
have cookies I want you guys to treat
yourselves to yourself a little snack
[Music]
that is the best champagne top I've ever
been in my life
it wasn't even any phone it's just
smoking like a beautiful potion out of
Harry Potter the beautiful magic that it
is and I brought my glass that has my
initial on it I didn't buy it for myself
it was a gift don't ever buy yourself
something with your initial on it I'm
extremely nervous so let's get to it I'm
struggling with my outfit but were the
women what did you guys think of the
women tell all looks I always like to
talk about it and I have to say I didn't
love any of like I thought all the
ladies looked beautiful it's just none
of them stood out as like amazing
outfits to me in the past like I
remember Danielle Maltby she had a
beautiful white pantsuit just sometimes
there are great looks and I didn't love
any of the looks but tell me who your
favorite was or your least favorite
whatever we're outfit judging here not
person judging just a reminder I put ice
in this champagne because I forgot to
put the champagne in the fridge
elevated ratchet
we just saw Colton jump that fence and
pretty much quit the show I want to get
your take on that
so I'm the Telos we always have a lot of
filler right a lot of recaps we've got
to do that but right off the top we had
Heather and Sydney making a point
they both wondered if I were him I don't
know how he can go on with the show
after confessing his love and really
having only Cassie on his brain I don't
know how you couldn't continue on and
pick one of the other two girls I
couldn't look Taoiseach and hand on the
eyes after that
how can Colton go on with the other two
women after what he said to Cassie and
my question for you is do you guys agree
or like Kenny totally go on and maybe
end up with one of the other women
because that's the show and anything
could happen that's how I feel I truly
don't know what will happen from here
tell me what you think will Colton end
up with Cassie
Hannah gee Taoiseach remember he said he
would fight for Cassie and that she was
the only one he was thinking about dwell
he was with the other women but we still
haven't seen the Energy's fantasy suite
I don't think it's gonna be with taste
chef I'll be honest
cheers to Taoiseach also because her my
favorite date of hers the coldness with
wine and snacks a lot of filler and a
lot of shameless plugs are coming in
this episode of rose and Rosie because
of course easy was at the women tell all
taping special and I was interviewing
everybody so I'll tell you guys what to
look for cuz but that's what that's cool
so let's say hello to my lady all right
we start off with demi applauding
herself
love it cheers to you dummy I can't lift
my arms higher than this but she could
the higher the arms the closer to deme
art demigod what's a demigod isn't a bad
thing anyway love Demi don't love
Courtney's facial expression here don't
drink every time Courtney looks just
like she wants to punch somebody in the
face not a good luck not a good look
where's spent the outfit one of the
feuds that definitely took up time on
yaeko Nicole then we have on Yaga versus
Nicole so speaking up don't drink every
time the cold looks like she's about to
cry
there's wanna give Nicole a really quick
lesson in vocabulary so on Yaga came
with her Miriam Webster memorization to
define bully for Nicole the definition
of bully is someone who intentionally
tries to intimidate someone that they
believe is inferior to them and she also
came with her ariana grande just say
thank you next thank you next but I'm
saying thank you next to this entire
interaction because I'm over it I mean
what do you guys think do you think that
on yank a bullied Nicole my take is no I
don't think so and the other women kind
of had some harsh words for Nicole as
well so whose side are you on here
Nicole on Jenka and let's be honest
we're gonna see them both in Paradise
aren't we and I'm okay with that
we're getting a lot of tears and a lot
of noise maybe on Yankee we'll bring her
foghorn but my favorite part of this
moment is that Nicole just starts saying
I need a boy I need a boy I'm drowning
you're like I'm drowning like you're not
drowning get yourself up out of the
water and head to the waters of paradise
Nicole okay that's where you belong and
you don't need a voice you're talking
so Katie who are you talking about then
we get into Katie versus Kayla and I'm
just gonna drink every time we have a
new Feud please drink responsibly
so Katie was the woman who I sort of
forgot who she was pretty much all
season long I never really knew her name
but she left Colt and she was one of
those who left with a warning about the
other women but she didn't name names
and golden didn't ask well now Katie has
shown up at the tell-all and the towels
are always fun because people treat it
like an audition for paradise right I
mean who from the tell-all were you guys
surprised by like oh I was suddenly
interested in her like oh I suddenly
want her in paradise Katie was a
standout she really came to play and she
said who she was talking to Colton about
Chris Harrison astron she said I was
mainly talking about Kalyn and Cassie
why this was big you guys because of
course kirpa and Taoiseach had
questioned Kalyn Cassie's motives well
now katie is adding fuel to that fire
that's a lot of names to say I'm
impressed I got them all I was close
with them but I just saw that what they
seemed to value in their life at this
point in their life didn't seem to line
up with what Colton wanted and she says
that this conversation was Kalyn and
Cassie talking about how one of them
could win make a wine up with Colton and
one of them could end up being
Bachelorette and Katie says it was the
word winning I didn't felt like he was
something to be won and I do too you
shouldn't say you win this show although
we do say we win people's hearts like
what do you guys think is winning a
weird word to say here is it
unacceptable
or are we all acknowledge that this is a
competition show at the end of the day
the Bachelorette conversation did happen
on the bus from the airport in Singapore
to the hotel the conversation happened
on a bus and when will we put cameras on
buses when will it happen if you guys
remember I believe in our a lion Dyke
season there was a conversation that
happened in a van and there were no
cameras in the van get when you throw a
GoPro in a vehicle we should be filming
these people 24/7 that's my expectation
roll the tape anyway so here's the
conversation that happened I would love
to set the record straight so Kalyn then
gives her side of this conversation and
says look Cassie and I were just saying
what will happen to our friendship after
this if one
wins and one of us ends up Bachelorette
you know maybe we can still be friends
what do you guys think
did you believe Kalin's tale of this
convo or Katy's version of the narrative
I have to say oh it's tough I could see
it both ways I could see Kalyn Cassie
just like having that chat what will end
up happening he got a lot of down time
to talk to each other during all this
stuff guys also I want to give a
sidenote shout out to hanabi's face
during this whole conversation I said
Cassie if it's me at the end of this I
pray that you're the Bachelorette you
find your person she's like she was
given a lot of good face so she's like
I'm not gonna say anything but my face
is gonna say I'm thinking but let's get
into Hannah B versus Kailyn okay what is
the deal with you and Kailyn I don't
want to get into like our right our next
head-to-head was more of a crown the
crown wasn't it pageant gate is back
everybody and I'm here for it Hannah and
Kailyn both gave very pageanty answers
to Chris Harrison about how their
relationship was going these days they
said they're good with each other I
think we're good they're in a happy
place you know water under the bridge
they're like oil and water we just don't
mix that well they don't mix but
everything is fine but again they do not
get along at all but seriously
everything's good they can really
support each other even though they
don't like each other great very
political very pageanty run for
bachelor/bachelorette office ladies also
funny side note this woman who I don't
know sitting in the back it comes to
Kalin's defense I think you held
yourself with the highest of class and
she's like Kailyn you handled yourself
with dignity not once did you come up to
Colton talking about any of the other
girls which all of them had to do and
then someone's like came and called
tisha stupid be in our class you come to
a stupid [ __ ] I think that's time well
you have to stick up their sauce
[Applause]
I'm like I don't know who she was but I
hope she goes to paradise just so I can
listen to her talk I think Kaitlyn could
have used someone a little more
prominent in her corner
you know she could have used a bigger
name fight in her battle with her but
that didn't happen so anyway
shameless plug to our interviews with
Hannah being Kailyn should Hannah be or
Kailyn be our next Bachelorette hmm who
would you pick one versus the other
I'm leaning towards Hannah B and I'm
gonna tell you why later
don't go anywhere so I want to move to
Demi whoo oh yeah thank you
next up Demi versus Courtney mmm what am
i a rookie in here in the ocean the
ocean is paradise anyway so Courtney
says and I couldn't disagree more I love
everything dummy says and thinks she
says a lot of funny witty things she
does call me classless and she over here
yelling like this and also some
insightful ones and then Courtney talks
about how Demi called her a cancer and
it's so vile she says did I think you
were a lot of things yes but never would
I say something like that like girl
borrow Anya cos merriam-webster
dictionary it was a metaphor
it's fine I disagree cancer the house
was probably a little extreme last night
that I'm gonna continue my train of
disagree with Courtney Demi says fine
you were more like bedbugs like I forgot
you were there
I died Harrison was dying laughing and
you know what that was something of
substance that was a great joke goodbye
Courtney
oh but don't drink every time Courtney
calls Demi a child Timmy you act like a
child I was dealing with a child and and
then while I wanted to say goodbye to
Courtney we had to say hello because
Courtney calls Demi a child then storms
over to her and shoves a pacifier in her
mouth
you guys I had to tell you being at the
taping this moment was crazy because we
didn't know why Courtney was doing it
was a little bit scary I was like what
does she have in her hand it was very
aggressive and in my mind very not okay
and I also wondered where had that
pacifier been had she been holding on to
it the whole time
had she been sitting on it what kind of
sweat was on it
everybody's died sweat when you've been
sitting a long time I don't know if this
is a Lauren TMI moment Jessie give it
the hashtag on screen if you want but I
had questions and shameless plug I asked
Demi about them and she answered that
interviews up at et online calm Demi
addresses where she thinks that the
pacifier was and whether or not she
intends to filing to have of charges
against Courtney okay who did you guys
saw it with Demi or Courtney the answer
is Demi if you're siding with Courtney
what are you thinking anyway then we get
Demi in the hot seat ooh and Demi says
she is confident confident with my
sexuality you know it's 2019 it's the
time to embrace that and it is 2019 and
she is promiscuous promiscuous
you know I okay Debbie I didn't see that
coming you didn't have to say that I
loved you either you're gonna say that
but it's great sure great I love you
Debbie I'm comfortable with who I am
Sammi has brought a dictionary too and
she gives us her definition of maturity
I know who I am and I will continue to
be that for the rest of my life and I
think that's more mature than what some
people think maturity really is I love
it
I just love everything about this I'm
just so here for Demi and speaking of
words she hits all the big ones don't
drink every time Demi says emotional so
emotional for
vulnerable vulnerable side of me journey
journey she's checking the boxes and
packing the bags and heading to paradise
isn't she I can't wait to watch I do
wish that we gotten to meet dummies mom
because again remember Demi's funny and
dramatic but she also give us this
emotional vulnerable side of her with
the mom storyline she wasn't there and
she was clubbed I asked her why Appetit
talent I found I thought they were gonna
like bring her out as a surprise but she
gives a really good answer anyway
Nicole come join the hot seat and then
Nicole is a mod seat and before I can
even get this drink to my mouth I'm
gonna tell you that I was wondering why
is she there why do we care and I
realized it was for an integration with
halo top ice cream we need a branding
moment I understand it's made all the
tiers birthday I love to have a nice
career sponsor here at Rose cinemas I'm
just saying anyway and then Hannah beers
in the hot seat god I'm doing myself a
lot of reasons to drink drink lots of
late be mature don't be a child
don't be a bully and don't be a cancer
but be a bed bug so Hanna me is in the
hot seat and she talks the struggles of
growing up in pageant light and I come
from the pageants and for me it wasn't
always the best I would put on whatever
I thought people wanted to see in me and
her feelings for Colton how she moved on
and she wants to be loved fiercely but I
do I think we all deserve somebody to
love us in that way and how she didn't
want to wind up in kind of a Southern
tradition of getting married and having
babies so quickly and all I was thinking
is wow what a bachelorette storyline
were setting up here right right right
it was a lot of backstory and I liked it
I liked it it was not all about Colton I
feel like our last set of bachelor and
bachelorette it's like Beca kufur and
unfortunately her storyline was so much
about the re breakup I'm excited for a
bachelorette where the storyline is not
all about the previous breakup that's
what we got with Colton old was a virgin
it wasn't all about like oh here's who
he got dumped by and now I want to see
that happen with our Bachelorette and
I do feel like canopy has that you know
they were literally giving us content
giving us story about her and I think
she's got fun things to say she's
emotional I love her southern accent
I've said that before I will say Hanna
could use a little bit of just kind of
coaching a little media training they
tried to redo that toast and she still
it still wasn't great cheers to this
beautiful day together new experiences
she did say roll tie and roll time
Motorsports thing JC's nodding school
she went to her something and kaylynn's
in the hot seat so very different hot
seat Kalyn is all tears she is not over
this whole thing and she's just so sad I
think we all felt like we had a
connection we all felt like though there
was something there but with me like I
knew something was different and I was
like I'm not crazy I'm a very realistic
person at the point now where we're
talking about who the bachelorettes
gonna be filming is gonna start soon so
it's probably gonna be announced soon
and if we're just talking about our
frontrunners that we know have been sent
home like Hanabi and Kalyn I do think
Kailyn as much as I love her and as much
as I admire her so much for sharing the
story that she did and I think that she
seems you know like a really solid woman
I just worry that she is so sad over
Colton and again I don't want that to be
the Bachelorette storyline this year and
it didn't bode well that at the end here
the other women especially during the
tell-all have like kind of reinforced
this thing about her maybe being
manipulative and having dissin genuine
reasons for being there it's tough what
do you guys think who do you want to be
Bachelorette Hanabi Kalyn we don't know
what happens it could still be Cassie
Taoiseach pana gee we could throw it
back have somebody from the past let's
not do that we saw what happened with
okay then come comes out man we've seen
clips of Colton and the shower scenes
this whole episode which I love like
giving a little nod to that but I will
say his hair looked like he had just
come out of the shower could we throw a
lot of product in there oh it was a
little longer something I didn't love it
I didn't love the tie I didn't love it
just saying good-looking guy didn't love
the tie what were your thoughts anyway
Demi said something interesting to
Colton didn't she she said quote you
wanted to leave someone and I was
leading you thought I don't say I I
disagree with that I never really gotten
the vibe from Colton then he was like
looking for a woman to leave he seemed
pretty okay with be bobbing around with
somebody by his side I disagree and when
did you know it wasn't me because I felt
it all the way until the end then Kailyn
asks Colton about their breakup I
would've asked a different question
Kailyn said when did you know I would
have asked what happened and why
but Colton just gives her nothing you
guys are a breakup I didn't have
anything to say because I felt terrible
I didn't give you any closure and I
don't know there's anything I could say
now that that will yeah he said quote
don't know if there's anything else I
can give you now yeah yeah oh no Colton
give her more she needs to understand
she needs closure
she was crying give more to Kailyn she
deserves more why do you guys think that
Colton Kayla didn't work out I have to
ask you because golden didn't tell us
then Colton just kind of give us an
across-the-board across the panel
apology to everyone I think I can make
this statement for you and to everybody
sitting up there is as The Bachelor I
could have done things better Indiana
B's like you're a good dude
I think you're good dude and have a
great heart and I really thought she was
gonna say roll tide but she didn't
so things have all wrapped up but what
do you guys think should the women have
been harder on Colton
should Colton have had more questions or
thoughts or comments for the women
overall I thought a good episode of
women tell all
I enjoyed it largely because of Demi so
I just want to say cheers again to Demi
mmm and then Sydney
oh come is that a left field with a real
big question Sydney asked :
Colton I know that you're not that
versed in sexual innuendos so I'm just
gonna like keep it clear are you still a
virgin and what do you guys think we
know he didn't have sex with zatia we
don't know what happened from here I
want to give here a shameless plug
because I have been asking Colton
whether he's still virgin all season and
I just don't know that we're gonna get
that answer so I changed it up and asked
him hey when will you reveal it that
interviews up anything right now
also just a side note that whack my
weave thing came up again what does
whack my leads and I don't think Sydney
even knows what that means
does anyone it doesn't sound sexy let's
never say it again nailed it and then we
got bloopers and I love the bloopers and
is cold Chris Pratt colton sound even
looked so much like Chris Pratt in this
little bloopers montage it really struck
me yeah that was close close nailed it
but you know what it was funny I liked
it I feel like we always see this goofy
side of the lead in the bloopers at the
end and then they're like nobody saw my
goofy side Aziz long it's like was a
reality show about drama like starting
you can say that you were funny but like
we love you okay and then we get the
trailer for the finale and shameless
blog so talk to both Colton and Chris
Harrison about how cold and winds up
filming again his way back in January he
told me yes he does return to the show
after the fence jump so what happens why
does he return what makes him come back
and Chris Harrison said
production crew was left in tears by all
this I love the behind-the-scenes stuff
guys I know that or you know that so
check those interviews out oh my god
speaking of Tears we see Colton's a cry
and whose door is cold knocking on whose
door is that white door I have to know
we didn't get to see poor Hannah jeez
fantasy suites just like I didn't need
me only my snacks yet so shout out to
Angie in my mouth I love you guys leave
your comments below dude actually my
dream I don't know why I married am Sam
and know that that was like accidental
ASMR probably but like also not very
good ASMR I love a smart you guys anyway
so the finale is next week oh my god
two-part finale Monday and Tuesday it's
live JC and I'll be all over it we love
you guys so much leave your comments
below buddy